hello this is Eric Weinstein I'm going
to be recording a short introduction to
this episode because I think it's
probably the most important episode of
the portal to date that said under
normal circumstances I probably would
have either edited this heavily or not
released it at all
it starts off quite slow and it gets
quite awkward before finding its pace
now what's going on is that the
interview subject is none other than my
brother Brett Weinstein in Brett's case
you probably know him if you know him at
all as the heroic professor who stood up
against what can only be described I
swear I'm not making this up as an
Maoist insurrection at an American
College in the Pacific Northwest the
Evergreen State College it was a very
strange situation because somehow the
national media that we would normally
have thought would have covered such a
story for example the media that covered
the takeover of straight Hall at Cornell
in the 60s that media was almost absent
completely at least they were absent for
a very long time before they entered
late in the game and why is that because
the story ran counter narrative that is
the students at the Evergreen State
College who were behaving in a racist
fashion were actually students of color
and this was an exactly counter
narrative story and Bret had it who
stood up to this racist insurrection was
in fact somebody with a history of
standing up against racism he had in
fact been a student at the University of
Pennsylvania my alma mater an Ivy League
school and had had to leave because of
death threats what he stood up for women
of color who were being abused for the
amusement and the sexual amusement of
white fraternity students so Brett was
supposed to be familiar to many of you
from that from an old national news
story and he was also the hero of a book
called the tapers morning bath but
somehow the news media who chose not to
report on the Evergreen story was not
very interested either in figuring out
who Brett was because the stories showed
that there was a contradictory problem
with the main narrative in some sense
that's quite some sense that's going to
be recapitulated in this episode there
is an official narrative about what
happened in the scientific episode and
there is a narrative which i think is
much closer to the truth which I happen
to be one of a very small number of
witnesses to this alternate story
now the key question is whether to tell
the story or not and you're gonna see
that both of us have a certain amount of
trepidation and energy around the
question of whether or not to break a
long-standing public silence when Brett
found himself as professor in exile
along with his wife Heather huiying I
had thought that the American biology
establishment would realize that one of
their own had been thrown overboard as
jetsam and that he would have been
invited to many universities to give
seminars in biology and it took a while
for me to understand that because he was
found at the Evergreen State College the
people who taught at highly ranked
research universities thought that Brett
was something more like a teacher rather
than a researcher in fact he had been
the top student of one of the most
important evolutionary theorists in the
United States Richard Alexander at the
University of Michigan as well as a
student of Bob Trevor's formerly of
Harvard arguably one of the greatest
living evolutionary theorists I think
presently at Rutgers Brett was somebody
who had actually done really interesting
work in his thesis and for some reason
the system found it very disturbing to
consider the full implications of his
work I think in this episode we're going
to do something interesting
I see Brett in two separate ways on the
one hand I view him as a very heroic
figure and he's an absolutely brilliant
person it's been a pleasure sparring
with him throughout my life however I'm
also his older brother and you're gonna
hear me it's sort of my overbearing best
browbeating him a bit now the point
isn't to push him down but quite the
contrary I'm rather competitive as
Brett's older brother and I don't want
to compete with the weakest version of
Brett the professor in exile instead I
want him seated again inside of the
institution where he always belonged and
in order to do that I want him to tell
the tale not with embellishment but as
it actually happened because I think
it's one of the most fascinating
episodes in modern biology that I've
ever heard so I hope that you like it
we're gonna put it in front of you as an
experiment and we're gonna test to see
whether or not I'm correct that the
portal can be used to augment the usual
channels
I believe that a lot of us are sitting
on intellectual gold I don't think that
the story that somebody's work didn't
say the light of day or got attributed
to somebody else is as exotic as the
institution's would have you believe in
fact I think it's quite common I think
many of us find that we don't have
careers inside of science because
something goes wrong quite early when
we're quite vulnerable and my hope is is
that some of you listening who I know
are struggling as graduate students or
as postdocs or as undergraduates will
listen to this and find some courage to
stand up for yourself because quite
frankly if you choose not to do it in
order to make nice with your fields the
chances are you will probably won't have
a career in the long term you might as
well swing for the fences and you might
as well clear your throat and tell your
story as it actually happened without
fear I don't know that this is going to
succeed but we're gonna run an
experiment and I think both Brett and I
are up for it to find out wherever it
goes the one thing I would say is that
if anyone else in the story wants to
tell their version of events it would be
an honor to have you on the portal there
are no bad people in this story in my
opinion there are a lot of bad
incentives and if we're going to
actually fix the system we're going to
have to look past the interpersonal but
the point of this in my opinion is is
that I think it's sufficient to open the
case again and a seat brett weinstein
inside of the university system that is
the research university system where he
has always belonged so have a listen and
i hope you like it
[Music]
hello you found the portal I'm your host
Aaron Stein and I'm joined today by none
other than my own brother dr. brett
weinstein brett welcome thanks for
having me okay well what should we do
what do you think Wow well I don't know
I would imagine a certain fraction of
your audience is going through the usual
sort of they randomly call us either
Brett or Eric yes so far as I can tell
which our parents also did while we were
growing I suppose that's true but
including the pets names we're also
sometimes thrown in if I recall
correctly that's true okay so if you
don't mind I was trying to think about
the fact that we have an opportunity to
do something that might be slightly
different because you and I share a lot
and what I thought is that we should
begin to really focus on areas of your
expertise with respect to biology rather
than the way in which many people have
come to know you so can I ask you to
just quickly dispense with in 30 seconds
how the world has come to recognize you
if they recognize you at all sure to the
extent that I am recognized it is
typically as a result of the meltdown at
Evergreen and my stance its Evergreen
State called the Evergreen State College
in Olympia Washington where I taught for
14 years along with my wife Heather
huiying who taught there for 15 years we
faced a mob of people who accused me of
racism and these were students they were
students I had never met and the event
was so colorful and eventually when the
world caught on to the fact that the
protesters who became rioters had
uploaded footage to the net and so the
whole event could effectively be seen
from their perspective it raised
interest in some other quadrants so for
example I ended up on Joe Rogan's
program which was the place I'm probably
most recognized from and you know the my
first appearance there we talked about
the evergreen situation and anyway
that's that's the the bulk of how people
know me all right so you were a
biologist teaching at a relatively
obscure college that had previously been
known for social activism and I didn't
love your introduction because when you
say well the students accused me of
racism that leaves sort of a weird
question like why was he accused of
racism let me solve the puzzle just
immediately maybe you can't do this
because that was the closest we'd seen
to a Maoist takeover inside of the
United States of America
ever like it was a case of mass insanity
and the videos showed it to be mass
insanity and unless you had been
indoctrinated to believe that Maoism of
some form Maoist re-education was normal
the rest of the world said oMG what the
heck is going on at this completely and
say and it wasn't just like one of these
college craziness pieces this is really
an episode of broad institutional
madness that was localized there and I
just I want to take it to be
self-evident because it is self-evident
the video exists and if you took the
people who were trying to pretend that
you were a racist in their own terms
that was sufficient - it was like the
unreliable narrator they were they were
debunking themselves in the eyes of
everyone who hadn't come under the spell
of this particular kind of madness well
there's a little little more to it in
the sense that they were entirely
unprepared for a white guy willing to
say no I'm simply not a racist and it
just didn't occur to them that that was
going to happen and it didn't occur to
them that my own students weren't going
to flee to their side at the point that
they leveled their accusation because
those things would have been normal in
this environment but in my case I grew
up in a home there are plenty of flaws
in that home as you know but one of the
places I don't think it was flawed was
that it was very clear-headed about
issues of inequality race justice and so
I I really have the sense that it's
these issues were really not new to me
and I had a long history at the college
lots of students of color you're
explaining too much I don't mean to be
rude about it but they were just crazy
they were crazy but my point is the
accusation is in and of itself so
powerful in modern circumstances that
people the idea of standing
- it doesn't occur to most people and
the fact is I was not well enough
positioned the thing descended into
madness it descended into literal
anarchy with armed students roving the
campus the same mob was looking for me
searching car-to-car for example was a
very dangerous situation laser bullets
but but what I'm getting at is I checked
with myself and did not feel vulnerable
to this accusation I felt most people
could not endure it but I was in a
position to and in an odd way you've
been effectively driven out of your own
University as an undergraduate standing
up against racism indeed these people
had flipped the script and said if you
don't sign up for our racism you're a
racist yeah they didn't I don't you know
here's the thing I I have two documents
that I've studied have a lot of
longevity to them one begins with we
hold these truths to be self-evident and
the other one begins within the
beginning and I think we've made a huge
mistake taking this as an argument it's
a non serious position held by morons
and idiots or people who have been
indoctrinated and infected with an idea
that there is something left-wing about
being a racist I'm not interested in and
I also think that it's really important
to stop giving these people their due
like it's really important to exclude
them from the conversation because if
you have to have a three-day symposium
as to whether or not racism can be
redefined in a way that makes it
impossible for certain people to be
racist but impossible for other people
not to be racist
there's just no point there just it just
needs to be thrown in the garbage
because it just it's a suicide idea that
wastes everyone's time and plunges the
world into stupidity madness and hatred
well you and I are in total agreement
about the necessity to shut the bad
actors rate out of the the conversation
I do have some concern about a large
number of people who fall into one of
two camps they're either confused or
they suffer from so much cowardice that
they will sign up for ideas that they
ought to know
wrong yeah but I think you're not
getting the message we've made a huge
mistake and I refuse to spend time
because these people have decided that
this is a tax that we should pay that
they have a serious point it's a non
serious point it's a terrifying moronic
non serious point that you can redefine
racism to be anti racism and anti racism
to be racism nobody knows this better
than me great okay are we done we are
good with that aside my concern you know
that I play this game which is called
what is the least interesting
interesting thing about X where I take a
person and I take their top
characteristic so for example the least
interesting interesting thing about
Dolly Parton is that she's busty the
most interesting things is she's a
genius level songwriter and a fantastic
singer and entertainer and a great
businesswoman doesn't matter but the key
point is we get hung up on some stupid
superficial characteristic and we don't
see the actual interest or Majesty in a
person and I feel like that has happened
to you I feel like it's some level
having known you for a very long time
you are an incredibly interesting person
for totally different reasons than the
reasons for which you have become famous
and I would like to use this this
episode you're by the way you're welcome
back anytime love to do a series with
you love to you know make this a regular
part of our lives if people like it cool
I think you know you and I both hear a
lot of curiosity about what our
relationship is like and what our
discussion sounds like and so I think
there's lots of memory of that what I'd
like to do is to try to be the foil for
you that I don't think anybody else can
be because I've actually I was tracking
this story very early and by the way
when I originally tried to get you help
and allies I think almost the only
person who could get what was happening
at Evergreen State was our mutual friend
sam harris who was willing to amplify
and retweet this because it was so
confusing that most of the rest that
we'll just never seen these kinds of
arguments i mean now it's much more
common for people to be aware of these
problems but when it started happening
we didn't even have any frame
for how to think about these yeah and in
fact Sam I remember even the content of
his tweet where he entered this
discussion where he suggested that what
was necessary was ad programming for
these people and from living inside of
this very confusing scenario to hear a
message of reason from the outside that
it was visible how insane this was meant
a lot to me really it changed things it
was like a reality check
Sam is Sam's a real hero in that regard
it's just amazing that he got it there
early and he got there correct and you
know more power to him yeah okay I as
you know I was not happy about you being
at Evergreen State College long before
this problem was occurring I viewed you
as sort of retreating into this very
obscure College and using the
undergraduates as if they were graduate
students teaching very advanced concepts
and running kind of a weird Harvard
style program with very adventurous
material with no recognition that this
kind of unusual educational environment
was even occurring fair unfair well it's
mostly fair it was not really an
appropriate place I don't regret it I
think for the last year or two Heather
and I were living on borrowed time if
this could have come for us in a worse
way and it could have come for us at any
moment but the the thing about the job I
had was that it was the upside of a
crazy experiment in education the
founders of the college had broken every
rule of a Normal University and half of
what they did in breaking it was crazy
and half of what they did was brilliant
nobody ever bothered to separate the two
from the prototype and you know fixed
the broken part didn't happen but the
administrators had no power and very
little knowledge about what was going on
in the classroom which meant that I
could create a learning
environment that worked both from the
point of view of students and worked
from the point of view of me in my
objectives to keep advancing a research
program that frankly I would have had no
way to keep on at a normal college I
would have been so burdened by teaching
that I couldn't have combined the two
things so anyway I do think one has to
figure out how to make their way in the
world
financially one has to figure out where
to raise their kids and from many
perspectives as much of a mismatch as
evergreen was for me in some ways in
some other ways it was not a bad place
to be
part it gave me I was anonymous from the
point of the world and I could make
progress on biology so I have fewer
regrets than I might okay this is so
uncomfortable but it is also the real
substance of our relationship I always
resented the fact that you really
excelled at and enjoyed teaching as much
as you did and you saw this in terms of
a place to play with ideas to teach
students to have a pleasant and
enjoyable life healthy as it was in the
great outdoors etc etc blah blah blah
and I still see these characteristics it
you what it drives me nuts because
you're your own worst enemy in some ways
to me what you really are to me is an
unbelievable thinker and researcher and
beneath this kind of very nice friendly
pedagogue is a thinker that the world
doesn't know and I watched recently your
interactions with Richard Dawkins and it
was absolutely infuriating I mean he's
very clear saying well Brett is a real
hero so far as free speech and standing
up for free inquiry goes but he's very
confused well no I don't think that
that's right I think that you guys had a
really substantive interaction about
biology which I wish he would spend more
time on because he's phenomenal at it
when he's focused on it
and you're phenomenal and that was
supposed to be a really different
conversation but because we got to know
you the wrong way in my opinion you're
always the guy who is strong enough to
stand up to students at an obscure place
and this completely masks who you've
always been and you're not willing to
take up the yoke which is the more
important role for you well I don't know
that I'm not willing I think you and I
have a different approach to this and it
may be you know birth order stuff or
whatever but you know and I also I have
the benefit of you in the world doing
what you do which I do wonder sometimes
what would have happened to me at
Evergreen had I only had my own tools at
my disposal it's quite possible I would
have been effectively snuffed out in
private and I don't know what I would be
doing at the moment as it happens the
evergreen story turned into rocket fuel
that propelled me into a strata where
there's lots of interesting things to do
that may not be exactly what you're
talking about but they they make sense
yeah it's frustrating
I'm trying yeah I don't think you
understand what it is that I'm trying to
do here I believe that your
miscategorized
and you're really not grasping that this
is my opportunity no I am I am grasping
what what I think distinguishes us is
that we have very different styles with
respect to approaching things I for
example take a certain perverse pleasure
in watching Dawkins slowly move in my
direction which I believe is happening
now I would like him to move faster he's
not a young man and I think it's
actually quite important that he
recognized where the errors in his own
thinking are and to be honest I believe
I know where at least several major ones
live and I know what he would see if he
could be brought to understand the
nature of those errors and to confront
the frankly the portal that opens if you
walk through a slightly different door
than he's been walking through
but you know it didn't work in one
evening I always wondered if it would
but there is still the possibility that
he will have the Epiphany that I hope he
will have I I really don't understand
even where we are in this conversation
ok ok you're not getting it you were
found at Evergreen State College that is
a communication to the world that you
weren't very good and every time I try
to say this is completely wrong
you miss you don't catch the ball that's
being thrown to you which is you're not
understanding what you're up against he
doesn't take you seriously because you
don't have a list of publications that
speaks to who it is that you actually
are or what you've done
or where you've been and as a result you
continue to be the good guy who's very
well-spoken very thoughtful it says very
interesting things and constantly gives
away power to other people mmm I don't
think so there's a question about how to
confront the opportunities that you've
got the hand you've been dealt and I
think you and I share a certain delight
when we do our homework and we discover
something interesting and absolutely
nobody else gets it hmm that would feel
bad to most people because they would
feel like what am I doing wrong why does
nobody else understand this point to you
and me that feels good it is to know
that you have achieved something you
have discovered something and that
nobody else can even recognize it gives
you some sort of sense of how far ahead
you might be the question is what to do
with those things and there I think the
question is if I went through something
with I said something intemperate to the
New Atheists and suddenly Steven Pinker
Jerry Coyne
Michael Shermer Richard Dawkins and Neil
Shubin came at me all at once not on the
topic that I had caused a fence on a
totally different topic they had picked
something off my youtube channel Jerry
Coyne had claimed to have debunked it he
was wrong but nonetheless it provided
fodder for them to attack their point
was that I didn't understand natural
selection and that to the extent I might
believe I knew something that other
people didn't know the right thing to do
was to submit it to a journal and go
through peer review I pointed out to
them that peer review was not Richard
Dawkins style and that he in fact
advanced the ball for the field
substantially but has barely published a
paper that backed them off that course
and their tune changed too well how
about a book then that's what Dawkins
did and to me that's a win the idea I'm
not against peer review I want peers to
review my work but I don't want it
snuffed out in private and so to the
extent that that little battle was a the
result of them under estimating me and
not knowing that something was going to
come back that was cogent and responsive
to the world as it actually is and
having them back off their position and
say yes actually a book would be a fine
thing that was positive movement from my
perspective they underestimated me and
they had to back down so I can't regret
that too much to me on a different time
scale I believe I'm making progress
toward a goal that you and I agree is
the right one but I'm not sure that
coming at it guns blazing is the way to
go well I'm happy to stop the interview
right here and right now because that's
adorable and it's sweet and it's
incredibly patient and it's it's a
beautiful sentiment but I also feel like
I sat through all of the wars and
battles to get your ideas into the world
and I'm not funding that program does it
sound to you like I'm surrendering no it
sounds to me like you're boring me like
this is really uninteresting but I think
about what actually happened yep this is
a miss telling it this is not even
honest okay floor is yours okay I want
to talk about something I'm calling the
disk the distributed idea suppression
complex and it has nothing to do with
Richard Dawkins and peer review and
Jerry Coyne and a bunch of other things
that almost nobody cares about it has to
do with about a 50-year period in which
great ideas got buried no matter where
they occurred because great ideas were
luck were very likely to be highly
disruptive to an institutional order and
between you and your wife and me and my
wife three of our four theses ran into
incredible problems because they were
trying to break really new ground and
the amount of delay that you suffered I
mean you're now 50 years old this is a
very late start in a career you're
coming from a very inauspicious place
you've been fitted with a story which is
he's a sweet guy who stood up to a mob
and that's his claim to fame and you're
not really understanding that you're not
being taken fully seriously as a
biologist in part what Jerry Coyne is
saying to you is hey you you're really
unknown to us I'm at Chicago Richard
Dawkins was at Oxford you know he was
the Simoni professor for the public
understanding of science right the point
is you're not part of the super Club
don't don't get confused you're just
some guys stood up oh I understand
that's what's being said okay so my
point is I don't have time for your
fairy tale about a healthy and in kind
and Sue's anything about healthy look
I'm interested in winning for
couple of rays but one the payload yeah
the insight that opens the portal to the
part of biology we don't know because
we've had bad Darwinian tools and for
those who heard that as an attack on
Darwinism it is not Darwinism needs
fixing there's nothing wrong with what
Darwin contributed it's what happened
after we do me a favor yeah I really
you've got your own podcast it's called
the dark horse right the dark horse
podcast I think this is a great place
for you to explore gradual change
incremental progression turning minds
around opening hearts all this stuff
this isn't your podcast this is my
podcast right but we're talking about my
life am i right
that we are talking about your life but
if that's what you want to do I don't
know that I'm that interested in doing
what I was going to do which was to try
to get your ideas out into the world
curated by somebody wasn't you you know
one of the things and by the way I've
had this issue with you do I take it we
are now not in a podcast at the moment
we are in a podcast Oh believe me I'm
gonna put the hurt on you because you
are you backing out of your role in
history and I am sick of it look one of
the things look I love you like like you
were my own brother amazing okay it is
the case that you have always done this
and it means that you're not taking your
place properly and I had to go to the
extraordinary lengths of tricking your
advisor Richard Alexander one of the
great evolutionary theorists of our
times and absolutely right one of the
absolute tops
remember the National Academy of
Sciences chaired professor at University
of Michigan I had to trick him into
writing a letter of recommendation for
you so that we would have some record as
he was getting on in years of who you
actually were because I knew that
Evergreen was not going to be it's not
it's not part of the game it's true okay
here's what he had to say about you
Brett Weinstein may well be the
brightest graduate student I have ever
known his thesis defense involved only
one of his four thesis chapters in it
alone was far more than sufficient as a
thesis I don't know anyone who knows
more than Brett about not only a wide
variety of topics in biological
evolution but the problems and
possibilities of cultural change and the
means of bringing people together in
solving difficult problems for 40 years
I held frequent sometimes almost daily
seminars with my doctoral students in
evolutionary biology while he was a
student Brett was a major element in all
of those seminars when he spoke there
was almost always respectful silence
even when he was junior to most of the
people involved Brett's thesis topics
are so significant in timely and so well
treated on the lifetime patterns of
humans and other species the function
and importance of telomeres in
explaining lifetimes as hedges against
cancer and several other important
topics such as species diversity and
sexual selection that he dramatically
converted on the spot to reluctant and
by the way reluctant is British
understatement here I will say mildly
and skeptically evolutionist members of
the committee I think that despite his
youthfulness in terms of the
characteristics I listed earlier Brett
is the best candidate you were the
number one student of Richard Alexander
who ended up at the Evergreen State
College which was a giant mistake and it
was always a mistake you should never
have been there
I was completely right I'm sorry to be
overbearing about it but like how many
years did I tell you you got to get out
of that place well look first of all
dick was very clear with me about the
fact that were he trying to compete in
the modern Academy he did not believe he
would have succeeded and he he was clear
about the fact that there was no good
solution to the problem so you know I
can't I can't say that I've ever heard
that letter I believe you have quoted
parts of it to me but yeah because
because you're gonna do this thing where
you downplay your gift and I'm sick of
it I'm tired of it I've just have had it
and part of it what happened is that you
are now distorting the history of
you have a place in the history of
science that you are not taking up you
are not advocating for there's something
that you don't like about this no no I
don't I don't think this is true I just
think I'm pursuing it maybe I'm pursuing
it in a way that it doesn't work out in
the end
or maybe I'm pursuing it in a way that
it would maybe there's more than one
I've been through too much helping you
trying to make this happen where people
become aware of the complex of ideas
that you've been pushing out and my
feeling about this is that you maintain
this very beautiful very calm position
and it's enough already like you have
you have a story and that story is an
explosive story I mean I'm happy to bury
this podcast so that nobody ever hears
it but I want to actually explore the
truth rather than this extremely good
for you high fiber you know loesch low
sugar bowl of granola I just don't think
that's where we are I've been very clear
and very public about the fact that I
think my entire field is spinning its
wheels that they've gotten caught by a
few bad assumptions and that they are
spending decades in the weeds for no
good reason that there is a way out that
I didn't know what it was for a long
time I did figure out what it was and
getting their attention on the question
of what they're doing wrong is a
Herculean task I've made that clear the
question is what is the best use of the
opportunity that I've got the cards that
I hold and we have a difference of
opinion about what that might be and you
may be right I'm not saying you're not
right but I am saying that there's at
least a discussion to be had about what
the best way to play though why don't we
hit that in your podcast I accept your
invitation to come on this is my podcast
we're gonna do it my way let's do it
your way all right I'm the older brother
I've noticed I have the ultimate
Marshall Marshall market problem all
right
Bret this is not the story of your
career in your life what happened is is
that you got stuck at the University of
Michigan for a very long period of time
because you made people very
uncomfortable what he's saying in that
letter of recommendation is is that you
wrote for different theses so far as I
can
remember and they were on widely
different topics furthermore here's an
interesting one no one that I know of
despite the amount of discussion that's
been spilled in ink over Evergreen has
put you together with the hero of a book
called the tapers morning bath that
appeared years earlier like odd that it
never shows up right it never shows up
and then you're also the you know
recipient of the golden gazelle award I
think of the national organization of
women for standing up to zbt at the
University of Pennsylvania and you it
got ejected effectively from an Ivy
League school due to like threats of
physical violence for standing up for
black women being exploited by white men
I mean like then you're like the field
assistant and main student as an
undergraduate of another legendary
evolutionary theorist Bob Traverse and
somehow you know Richard Dawkins is
treating you as a guy who isn't really
his equal he's you're not really a major
theorist you're very confused and you
need to learn more about the extended
phenotype and all this kind of nonsense
and you're so polite that you're not
even it's just I don't know I think
you're out to lunch no offense I get it
I get it and you know like I said you
may be right okay I want to talk about
the subjects that you're most associated
with starting with your thesis and I
want to get into the science of it using
the portal podcast if people get left
behind they get left behind okay okay
now Dick Alexander is a legend in
evolutionary theory because it it's very
hard to use evolutionary theory to make
predictions that can be verified in the
world it's it's sort of like this loose
amorphous collection of techniques and
viewpoints and people sometimes think
it's not even a theory because it
doesn't seem to be predictive and then
there are a few predictions so am i
right Darwin started this game off by
predicting that there would be a moth
with a really long tongue
because there was a flower that had a
really long distance to go before you
could get the nectar out of ya he had
been sent an orchid by Bateson maybe
with a foot long corolla tube and he
reasoned very straightforwardly that it
would make no sense for this plant to
have invested in this very long
structure if there were not a tongue
that could reach down to gather the
nectar and I believe he did not live to
see the discovery of that animal I'd
know that but he he was absolutely
correct there is a moth that has this
beautifully long tongue it's a spin Jude
hawk moth one of these sort of
hummingbird esque moths and anyway yeah
it's one of the major predictions
demonstrations that evolution color
theory actually can be used to predict
phenomena that you haven't been able to
observe okay and you know Darwin
famously couldn't for example like I
don't know how much I've talked about
this in the open but my favorite Darwin
book is the one he wrote after Origin of
Species which is on the various
contrivances by which British and
foreign orchids are fertilized by
insects it makes absolutely no sense is
it title because I think that's what's
so funny about it and but because
orchids are so highly speciated turned
out to be the perfect place to explore
the consequences of evolution and he
couldn't figure out my favorite I don't
whether it's clade or group it's pretty
safe
yeah clade of orchids the ophrys system
which is just unbelievable because it
mimics the pollinators the female of the
pollinator species using pheromone
pheromones and some sort of replica good
enough to fool males into copulating
with the lower petal of an orchid it's a
sturdy replica of the female yeah that
smells like her and it just so happens
that when the male lands on it to
copulate he gets these pollen packets
glued to him and then he screws up and
makes the same mistake at another flower
and he may he may or may not put it this
but only the ones that screw up twice
get to get to fertilize the reason that
it gets glued to him is that it has
worked enough times for this strategy to
have been so beautifully refined right
so Darwin saw that
there was this mimicry going RB couldn't
put it together you split the pages and
pages not getting it so I think it's
very funny so he predicts some things
but he can't predict something else in a
very closely related system okay fast
forward Dick Alexander comes out with a
crazy prediction which I still don't
fully I mean it's just amazing that he
made it where he says I bet that you
will find the kind of behavior we
associate with wasps and bees which is
in this clay called hymenopteran dance
of you social breeding patterns in an
organization but in mammals that will
live underground so I think the way this
story actually worked he didn't say you
will find or you could find what he said
is in principle there's no reason that a
you social animal has to be an insect
that in fact you could get such a thing
in a mammal and then he predicted I
forget how many characteristics there
were but he named some there's something
funny about the system of ants bees
wasps which is that they've got this
very strange haplotype loyd chromosomal
characteristic do you want to say a word
about that because that makes the
prediction more sure so it has long been
understood that the Hymenoptera behaved
in this incredibly cooperative fashion
in which effectively all of the workers
of the colony forego reproduction in
order to advance the reproductive
interests of the queen and it was late
discovered that actually their genetic
system is unlike our genetic system and
that males have basically half a full
complement of genes they have enough
genes to function but they have half the
female complement of genes and for
reasons that are mathematically slightly
complicated and require a chalkboard the
females are more closely related to the
daughters produced by their mother than
they would be to their own offspring
they're three-quarters relatives to her
offspring in there they would be 50%
relatives to their own house so they are
actually evolutionarily favored by very
standard
mechanisms once you understand the crazy
genetics underlying the thing they are
favored to engage in behavior where they
forego reproducing and once you
understand the chromosomal difference of
this system it is far less surprising
that it would behave as a loosely
coupled in some way don't over don't
overreact Hut unified organism which is
distributed that there is a way in which
and there are ways in which the hive
behaves as a super organism and there
are ways in which it does not
yeah well all I want to say is I'm not
sure how clear we have the story with
respect to what precedes what it's
completely plausible that the behavior
precedes the evolution of the genetic
system right and I actually frankly just
don't know where that research stands at
the moment we have found many other
insect systems that have various
versions of this interestingly though
the termites are not hymenopteran right
and the termites engage in this behavior
and they rights are you social but
they're not a political they're you
socially behave very much like ants okay
but they don't have the strange genetic
system proving that the the behavior can
involve even in the absence of this
genetic system well the reason I bring
this up is that if you if you look at
for example Prince Peter Kropotkin the
great anarchist theorist he was obsessed
by finding analogues in nature of
preferred human structures and so it's
very simple to say why can't we work
together the way an ant colony all works
together and then there's a counter to
that which is well they have different
chromosomal structures and then you say
well but yes but that's a kind of a
cheap way of achieving eusociality there
are other ways of it so we threw this
crazy kind of investigation we get to
Dick Alexander who and I think you're
quite quite correct says there is
nothing prohibiting us from finding a
mammalian species that exhibits ant and
wasp like behavior and it would have it
would be likely to have these
characteristics it would live
underground and uh yeah underground
I believe eating tubers was was ah it
was a crazy list raising and you know my
understanding from from dick dick is now
unfortunately dead he died a couple
years ago but
my understanding from him was that he
didn't actually expect to find such an
animal he was speaking very absolutely
just completely theoretically and at the
point that he unleashed this idea it may
even have been in a talk rather than a
paper the information made it back to
him actually what about naked mole-rats
they match your characteristics and
study reveals then that actually they
are you social they behave very much
like ants bees wasps termites etc and
just like one of the great moments in
modern science I really think it is it's
it's certainly the moment that people
who know who Dick Alexander was
reference as sort of the high-water mark
because it's it's comprehensible you
know did a lot of things he was very
interested in people and other things
but this particular demonstration was so
it would be impossible to have predicted
such a thing and have gotten lucky he
had to have understood some things that
were extremely deep in order for that to
have worked out and so yeah it's really
I don't know of another example in in in
evolutionary theory of a prediction that
clean of something that obscure I know
one oh yeah yeah I once heard a story
about a a graduate student who predicted
that the breeding protocols of
laboratory rodents would compromise the
laboratory system in terms of its
relationship to so-called wild-type
versions of the same species so you have
the bred rodents and you have the wild
rodents and that they would be
distinguished by virtue of the fact that
the non-coding nucleotide sequence at
the end of the chromosome known as
telomeres would be wildly different in
length
if the prediction were true from pure
evolutionary theory Wow yeah yeah
yeah that story it didn't happen exactly
the way you said it but you know it's
been a lot of years and take well
they're gonna get back there yeah I mean
it's you you did that yeah I did that
and that story unfortunately has not
really been told and it is in some sense
your central origin story as a biologist
it's a pretty good one and it definitely
changed the way I saw myself in a way
that has been very productive okay I
want you to talk to me about that story
and I will because I lived it with you
um I know that it happened and I know
that it got buried and I know that it's
part of what I'm calling the distributed
idea suppression complex because quite
frankly you were not the only person who
was a part of the story and the story
had to die because it said something
which is that the power of your theory
was sufficient to predict from first
principles a manifestly observed and
surprising result with in molecular
biology from pure evolutionary principle
yep all right I'll try to do a short
version of it you know this is long-form
podcasting and you tell however long the
story is I guarantee you when people
finally figure out that it may be that
the rodents that we've used to test
drugs on let's say might be compromised
and compromised in a way that would be
potentially extra permitting of
potential toxins in the form of
pharmaceuticals I think that it's going
to be fascinating it's going to be
repaid
it's going to repay the study that it
will take to understand the story the
floor is yours alright so let me just
set the stage a little bit evolutionary
biology whoo but do me a favor yeah like
you can get into a very patient careful
pedagogical mode this is an exciting
story tell it the way it actually I'm
going to tell it the way it actually
occurred and I'm gonna be careful I'm
gonna try not to be
there are parts of it that were for a
very long time kind of emotionally
fraught but anyway I think I think I
remember it well enough to do a sparse
but complete version okay
evolutionary biology has long been
biased in the direction of abstraction
rather than thinking about mechanism
that is to say we deal in the
phenomenology of things we talk about
gross patterns that we see in nature
rather than talking about the fine
detail of what drives them that has been
changing in recent decades but it has a
long history and it comes from a very
mundane place that mundane place is that
we just haven't had the tools to look
for example inside of cells and we
haven't been able to read genomes you
know we could have been able to read a
gene here and there at great expense but
the ability to peer into genomes is
pretty new the ability to peer into
these molecular pathways is pretty new
so anyway there's a historical bias in
evolutionary biology against mechanism
and in the direction of phenomenology I
have never been particularly fond of
that bias I have always been interested
in mechanism I'm interested in the
phenomenology too but I've always kept
my foot in the door with respect to
mechanism and as an as a undergraduate I
took lots of mechanism classes I took a
development class at the time
developmental biology was in my opinion
a bit stuck it is now unstuck in a very
dramatic way but anyway I took a
developmental biology class I took some
immunology or immuno biology and anyway
I was armed with these things in an
environment in evolutionary biology
where most people were not most people
were in the phenomenology and one day I
happened to be in a seminar dick
Alexander was running a seminar for
graduate students and a student was
there who was very out of place he was
studying cancer and he on a lark decided
to take an evolution seminar that looked
good to him in the catalogue and it
wasn't right for him and he gave a talk
at some point and his talk was on his
work with cancer and frankly because all
the other people in the room were
evolutionarily oriented nobody was
really tracking what he was saying
but what he said struck me like a bolt
of lightning he said that in the realm
of cancer research people were looking
at telomeres which are these repetitive
sequences at the ends of chromosomes and
they were toying with the possibility
that the fact that these telomeres
shorten every time a cell divides that
that is providing a resistance to tumor
formation very straightforward counter
counts down and that would prevent so
let's just for the audience that maybe
needs a tiny refresher we are taught in
general that DNA is a string of letters
called nucleotides AC T and G and that
in general three of those that are
adjacent to each other form words called
codons and for every word there is an
amino acid or an instruction to stop
coding for amino acids so this is the
instruction tape that tells us how to
string together amino acids into
proteins to make machines a molecular
machines this is some weird different
thing where the region of DNA could be
interpreted as coding for a protein but
in fact might be instead just counting
how many nucleotides are at the end so
it comes across as a counter it's a
little better it was known not to be a
coding sequence it wasn't a you see case
so what you had is a bunch of DNA at the
ends of chromosomes that's just
repetitive and the length of the number
of repeats varies and the number of
repeats correlates with basically how
many times the cell can divide before it
refuses this being interpreted as a
cancer prevention thing made perfect
sense but the reason it struck me like a
bolt of lightning was that I was well
aware of the existence of tumors and
their implication in something entirely
different what they had been implicated
in as far as I was aware was something
called hayflick limits which were the
tendency of perfectly healthy happy
cells to grow and grow and grow and
in a petri dish until they hit some
number of divisions and then to stop
without apparent dysfunction so so this
was the theory of Leonard hayflick yeah
it was the discovery of Leonard hayflick
who basically overturned the prior
wisdom about cells which was that they
would grow indefinitely as long as you
kept feeding him and making an
environment that was conducive to
division so I don't exactly know why
that result had been misunderstood at
first maybe somebody had a cancerous
cell line and so they got the wrong idea
and it just spread but hayflick checked
it and it turned out to be false turned
out there was a number of cell divisions
that healthy cells would go through and
then they'd stop the mechanism was not
obvious to a flick but later it became
clearer and clearer that the mechanism
was these sequences at the ends of
chromosomes which shorten each time the
cell divides and the implication was
that potentially this was a cause of
what we call senescence well in common
parlance would often be called aging the
tendency to grow feeble and inefficient
with age if your cells are each in a
cell line and that line has a fixed
number of times that it can replace
itself before it has to stop then some
point your repair program starts to fail
and that repair program failing across
the body looks like what you would
expect aging aging follows the pattern
you would expect if cell lines one by
one stopped being able to replace
themselves so we know that there's a
special sort of I don't want to call it
cell line because you can keep
correcting me for every tiny mistake I
make in speech but if we divide our our
body into two kinds of cells soma and
germ we're germ lines are that which has
a hope of immortality through
reproduction then it's the somatic cells
that have finite limits on their ability
to undergo mitosis and cellular repair
and and whatnot and the germline can't
because if it did you your lineage would
go extinct as a result of small
smaller than the small addendum so it's
the soma the parts of your body that
don't go on to produce babies that have
this effect the reason it's struck me
like a bolt of lightning was that I was
aware of another very elegant piece of
research done by a guy named George
Williams George Williams had finally one
of the greatest of modern one
illusionary one of the greatest modern
evolutionary biologists I actually knew
him a bit too he is also now gone
unfortunately but George Williams had
laid out in a beautifully elegant paper
the evolutionary theory of senescence it
is an absolutely elegant argument that
says that in a lifetime there are well
let's start somewhere else
a creature is built of parts and traits
it has a relatively small genome and a
relatively high complexity at the time
it was thought there might be a hundred
thousand genes or something and you have
maybe 30 trillion cells with a ton of
complexity in order to get that small
number of genes to dictate how to
produce a creature that complex the
genes are doing multiple things
Williams point was when a gene has
multiple effects what we call a playa
trophy those effects may be good or bad
if effects are good early in life by
good we mean contributing to fitness
fitness enhancing rates at some cost
late in life then they will tend to be
accumulated by selection and the reason
for that is because well there are two
ways to think of it really if a trait
occurs if a negative trait occurs very
late in life then a large number of
individuals who have the gene for that
trait will not live long enough to
experience the harm so if it came bound
to a positive thing early in life and
you're dead before the late-life harm
accrues you got away with it right so
Williams point was he was building on
earlier work of Medawar but let's skip
that for the moment his point was
because of trade offs you will have lots
of traits that are good and bad late
selection sees the early traits much
more clearly than it sees the late
traits and it prioritizes them because
of the discounting that arises because
so many individuals aren't around to
experience the late life harm and if
they are around to experience the late
life harm a lot of their reproduction is
behind them anyway so they count less
selection counts more early in life and
this timer starts at the moment of first
reproduction the usual moment of first
viability for your species so this is a
beautiful hypothesis and it was
beautifully articulated with many
predictions which is the way really good
work is done and we knew at the point
that I was entering graduate school we
knew that the the the hypothesis was
right it was a theory and the reason
that we knew it was really bothers is is
the antagonistic pleiotropy hypothesis
antagonistic pleiotropy hypothesis for
senescence we knew that it was right
because it predicted so many phenomena
in nature that we could readily go out
and measure and this is again where the
phenomenology versus mechanism comes in
okay we know that creatures that are
poisonous or have a shell that protects
them or can fly away from danger are
disproportionately long-lived
for their size small creatures tend to
live shorter lives them than large
creatures but if you can fly then you're
off the line of the other creatures of
your size so for example they're small
bats who have been recovered after 30
years in the wild so creatures that have
special protections have
disproportionate longevity this matches
Williams hypothesis because it is their
ability to fly away from danger that
makes the likelihood of they're
experiencing late life costs go up so
selection sees their late life more
easily than it sees a small creature I
just want to say something yeah this is
a podcast
it's an unusual podcast and we can talk
science and I'm thrilled but you we
always have our colleagues in our minds
when we're talking to a general audience
and the colleagues are always in a
gotcha mode well you
forgot about this you didn't mention
that I'm even interjecting little bits
because I want to make sure that you're
immunized from all the [ __ ] um that
the a cadet so I just want to make a
general statement which is we can come
back and get into any level of
specificity that somebody wants to if
they want to take you down I don't care
what I'd love to do is to tell the story
with enough punch that people understand
what happened we're about to jump into
the let's do the meat of the matter the
theory of antagonistic pleiotropy was
well established but in four decades of
research on the genome nobody had found
a gene that matched it so we knew that
this explanation was right but we
couldn't find the genes that caused it
the mechanism was missing so anyway need
to be a gene it has to be protein coding
yeah anyway I knew this a sort of me I
was well familiar with Williams paper at
the point that I saw this talk on cancer
and I knew already about the question of
senescence everything came together this
was obviously the answer where the
missing quiet ropey was well the missing
pleiotropy had to do with a telomere
which wasn't exactly a gene it was
genetic it was DNA but it wasn't a gene
but it was perfectly capable of
producing exactly the effects that we
see in senescence across the body tissue
account or not a protein could be the
answer now I saw this instantly at the
point I heard this talk I raised my hand
and I tried to articulate what was so
obvious in that moment and I couldn't
compel a single person in the room
they couldn't even understand what I was
trying to say and that is bizarre it was
bizarre meaning dick was in the room and
you know dick was very broad-minded and
I just couldn't make it clear ok let me
just interject something you can correct
me if I'm wrong but my impression of it
is that it was a very simple idea
attended to by an outrageous amount of
irrelevant complexity that had to be
very carefully pried off of the central
idea yeah I think I think that's well
well said so anyway I left the room
feeling like I had just glimpsed
something so important you know I
wondered could it be right and I started
to just do the first bit of library
research to figure out whether somebody
else knew what I knew or so I'm named
sure that you fully said it I want to
make sure that I mean been clear on it
and I'm gonna I think I'm right but it
correct me if I'm wrong what you're
saying is what if the hayflick limit is
a protection against dying from
immortality at a psychological level
that is some cell gets a dream of
immortality that it shouldn't have
because let's say it's a somatic cell
and it says okay I just want to keep
dividing and dividing dividing nature
knows how to do this and that
immortality which sounds good at first
is actually called cancer yeah and so in
computer science we would say okay
you've introduced a recursion limit into
a while loop or a for loop to make sure
that you don't have a resource leak
which is what a tumor is yeah so let me
say it this way if you have a damage to
a tissue cut on your arm or something
the cells on both sides of that cut
suddenly become aware that there is a
problem a gap because they can't hear a
neighbor on one side of them and their
natural reaction is to start growing
into the gap until they can hear a
neighbor which is the sign to stop if
you imagine that something like that is
occurring in every tissue there are
almost every tissue the problem is that
that means that every tissue in your
body for which that story is about right
he's in danger of having damage from
radiation or whatever
turn it deaf to its neighbors a single
cell that has turned deaf to its
neighbors will suddenly start
replicating and if it is deaf to its
neighbors then there's no message that
it's going to hear that's gonna tell it
to stop so that thing imagine any cell
in your body just taking off and growing
and growing and growing because this is
terrifying what you're saying to me is
is that if I'm comprised of let's say 30
trillion cells and I view them as each
let's say subroutines any subroutine
that is not D nucleated right like this
wouldn't have
in the in the lens of your eye because
the the nucleus has been removed but any
other reasonable cell is potentially
your assassin because it's mitosis
process might completely go rogue can
run away okay and so the rather elegant
and very simple idea is that there would
be a hard limit so that any cell that
had become damaged so it started down
this path would just simply run into the
number of cell divisions it was allowed
in a lifetime and it would stop so like
the moles on my face that some of my
less couth commenters love to talk about
yeah are effectively attempts to kill me
that may have stopped and that the
perimeter where they stopped is where
the hayflick limit took over and said
this the cell line must die so that the
patient will live yeah the name I gave
him was proto tumor and the idea is a
proto tumor is a patch of cells arrested
at their hayflick limit because they had
become unregulated if you go to the
dermatologist and you say what do I look
for you know they tell you certain
things to look for so a round patch of
cells that suddenly becomes irregular in
shape well that's what would happen if
you took one of those cells and gave it
a second mutation and it started growing
again got it right so anyway the idea
that a limit on cellular reproduction
yep is adaptive to protect you from
cancer there's a little bit of a mind
bender because what you're telling me is
is that I've got to avoid immortality
which can kill me and that the solution
to not dying is death yes and that what
selection does is it balances these two
competing forces to give you as much
vigor and longevity as all of the other
diseases and insults and things that I
can die from sort of start to fade away
and at the complete core of biology in
this theory there are two things that I
can't get away from one of which is
death by immortality and the other one
is death by recursion limit that's it
it's a very elegant thing and now the
problem is is that there's all this
weird attendant complexity that you had
to deal with right like stem cells
versus germ versus so when I went into
the literature what I found was that
people had played a
in the neighborhood but that there was a
particular fact which blocked every
attempt to make sense of what was going
on and the fact was that rodents were
understood to have ultra-long
hypervariable teen Lanier's and i didn't
know what that meant at first but the
more I looked into this possibility the
more I realized that dozens of
long-standing problems would be solved
if my hypothesis was true but that my
hypothesis couldn't be true because
basically mice have long telomeres and
short lives why is that
and I banged my head on the table for a
couple weeks trying to figure out what's
going on yes maybe even literally I'll
get on occasion but the question was I
began to wonder if there was something
wrong with the idea that mice had long
telomeres sometimes like in hay flix
case it turned out that a bunch of
people were copying some wrong result in
it so it seemed like a lot of people had
seen it but only one hand I checked was
it true that there was something that
everybody was parroting one study that
said mice had long telomeres and right
turns out lots of people had tested it
might have long telomeres like ten times
the length of human telomeres it just
didn't fit so finally it occurred to me
that it was possible that what was going
on I discovered something in trying to
figure out what they meant by mice right
might there's a lot of species of mice
but all the mice that we use in the lab
with rare exception are from one genus
and often from a particular target
species you were focused if I recall
correctly a moose praedyth's
no no not a schoolís mus musculus but
still common one yeah what shocked me
was that it turned out all the mus
musculus that were being used in labs
across the country and in many cases
farther afield than that were coming
from one place which I had no idea there
was one I remember getting a phone call
when you said what do you know about the
Jack's lab did Jack's lab in Bar Harbor
Maine right they seem to be the source
of everybody's mice and so it began to
be
it was a possibility I could not shut
down in my mind that there was something
about what was going on at the Jax lab
that had resulted in the mice that were
being sent out to all these other
Lassiter were representative animals
right these are model organism people
were just using mice because my sort of
convenient mammal but they're all coming
from one place and it began to occur to
me that that one place was not just a
source of mice in the sense that we
might think it it was actually a
selective environment that was impacting
those mice and when I dug deeper it
turned out that the mice had all they
were descendants of a long lineage that
had lived in captivity under conditions
at the Jax lab and at some point I
realized that the most likely thing
going on was that there was something
about this environment that had wildly
elongated the telomeres of these mice
and that was simultaneously an
unbelievable idea but the only one I
could think of that made sense of
everything I had seen and so well it's
unbelievable because the consequence of
it yeah I mean look I have not even
heard whether anyone has said yeah we we
did that we screwed that up but it is
like your MA your favorite model
organism from mammalian trials being
screwed up by a central facility because
also there's this weird thing where
medical people very often stop taking
into account evolutionary theory
because they treat that as well that's
that class I took in college or the
beginning of graduate school right so I
began to focus on this question and I
did something that was the right thing
to do but I did it in a way I will
forever regret I found somebody who was
represented in the literature who I
regarded as very well-versed they made
sense to me their papers her name was
Carol Greider Carol Greider is now a
Nobel laureate she was not at the time
she was the co-discoverer of the enzyme
telomerase which is the enzyme that
elongates telomeres when that occurs
with the famous in Co Nobel
that she was the student of Elizabeth
Blackburn Elizabeth Blackburn exactly
she was her student and they shared the
Nobel Prize with Shostak um in any case
her work seemed good to me I called her
up cold you know I went into the insect
division office and I sat down to the
phone I called her I said Carol you
don't know me I'm a graduate student at
Michigan I'm an evolutionary biologist
I'm racking my brains trying to
understand something can you tell me is
it possible that mice don't have ultra
long telomeres that it's only laboratory
mice to do and she said huh that's
really interesting I'm pretty sure that
mice have long telomeres universally but
it is odd that if you order must spread
us instead of mus musculus and you order
from European suppliers the lengths are
very different than what you get if you
order mus musculus from the tactics lab
and I said whoa and she said yeah that's
really interesting and then she said I
can't remember if it was the same phone
caller if we had a second phone call but
she said she was gonna put her student
her graduate student Mike Heyman who I
think is now at MIT on the project and
he was going to do a little work to
figure out whether there was anything to
this and Mike did some work they sourced
some different strains of mice that were
they were actually not wild mice might
wild mice would have been the right test
but she couldn't get wild mice for
obvious reason it's about the woods
right exactly and so she got several
different strains of mice that had just
been in captivity much less time she
actually got one strain of mice that was
treated very differently in captivity
but never mind
I should put her graduating on it he
measured their telomere lines and I get
this excited email Mike 'man sends me an
email that says effectively whoa the
hypothesis is true mice have short tail
here right now I'm sorry this is like as
close to a whodunit discovery
J'Accuse the mice you know I remember
you were over the moon I still am I
still can look at this email and it is
the moment at which I realize a
there's no way I'm kidding myself about
how well I understand this right right
that prediction was of you now or then
uh when you get this email I got that
email I was it was 1999 98 something
like that
okay so over 20 years ago yeah so I get
this email and by the way that puts you
at about 30 you're at the beginning of
your career and you in this story you've
just predicted because it's a stunning
coup for a graduate student and it
wasn't in my advisors wheelhouse so it
was clearly my own work and redic was
great about not okay you're a dirty dog
liar and I was there at the time yeah or
or so we're both dirty dog liars about
his particular story or or one of the
great moments in evolutionary theory
which is in let me just curate this
because I'm not a biologist but I think
I can more or less get this because it's
a breeding protocol that is the
alteration in the evolutionary landscape
for these laboratory mice and because
it's acting on a non-protein coding
region the adaptation to a change in the
breeding protocol can be extremely rapid
it doesn't have to undergo some sort of
completely crazy typical Darwinian story
about random mutation and some of them
being retained and others being rejected
it's it's even better than that the
creatures are presumably so we haven't
gotten to what the breeding protocol has
to do with this but the creatures are
built in some sense to detect how
dangerous their environment is and to
the extent that the level of extrinsic
danger changes their telomeres respond
quickly so that they are better adapted
to the environment so they're built to
detect the environment and then what is
actually a strict
matter of market forces okay so they're
no predators in this environment no
predators in this environment and we're
not killing them particularly early
based on their skills so the
environmental insult is sort of absent
environmental insult is more or less
absent what we are doing is imposing an
economic rule on breeding so that we can
maximize the rate at which we turn mouse
Chow into mice which is obviously
economically the right thing to do if
you're selling mice to all these labs
you're gonna produce as many mice as
cheaply as possible so producing as many
my sister changes to the market it's the
genius of the market so in order to
produce as many mice as cheaply as
possible what you do is you don't breed
animals past eight months they breed
faster when they're younger because of
senescence and so you don't breed older
mice you throw them out and you replace
him with younger mice who breed faster
what that effectively did was it
eliminated the selection against cancer
and it turbocharged the selection in
favor of useless forgiveness in general
almost all cancer the cancer of the
germline happens early in life but all
the other cancer in general is much more
common later in life I got a pause I
realized I forgot to tell you one thing
Carol told me in my first phone call
that's vital in addition to telling me
that there was something funny about mas
Freitas she told me that consistent with
the hypothesis that I was conveying to
her that all mice die of cancer she said
if you let him live long enough and then
you do the necropsy you find cancer of
one kind or another and that was
perfectly consistent because they had
these wildly long telomeres and no
cancer protection that would be the
prediction that high cotton it's it's
not really all mice it's all mice that
we see in the lab which happens to be
the mice that are ordered right she was
still speaking from the mindset of
somebody who thought that the mice she
was getting in the mail represent
representative of mice and the wad okay
so let me clear up why the breeding
protocol and I should say that it is the
breeding protocol that is causing this
that part I would say is still a
hypothesis
it has not been directly tested by
anybody but what I would say is many
hypotheses were tested in the aftermath
of the discovery that that lab mice have
bizarrely long telomeres and wild mice
don't and no other hypothesis has stood
up to scrutiny so does the last
hypothesis standing and I'm all but
certain that it will turn out to be true
yeah the reason that the breeding
protocol has this weird effect is that
when you throw out the mice at eight
months of age you eliminate selection
against cancer
you turbocharged selection in favor of
Zoar when you throw out the mice for
breeding purposes at eight months right
okay you throw them out for breeding
purposes at eight months of age you are
increasing the importance of their early
life breeding and you are discounting
anything related to their ability to
fend off cancer because they don't live
long enough in that period of time to
get cancers that kill them and so what
has happened according to this
hypothesis is that the mice that have
longer telomeres have driven out the
other animals from the colony the trait
of having long telomeres has swept
through the colony and the telomeres
have been elongated to an absurd degree
creating animals that do all die of
cancer
and interestingly enough another thing
that's evident from the literature is
that if you look at their tissues their
tissues do not age in the way that a
normal mammals tissues age they remain
young well so there's one aspect of
aging but that there's a far darker
[Music]
interpretation of what you've just said
if I'm understanding it correctly yep
never taking a class of biology but I
lived this adventure with you those
tissue have at a histological level the
level of how cells are organized the
possibility of radical histological
repair yes radical and effectively
indefinite capacity to repair which is
going to come back in the story in the
worst possible way so this is like it I
mean I just forget how great of me to I
go years sometimes without thinking this
story about it all right yeah okay so
the story now gets kind of ugly
I recognize I've got all the pieces of
the puzzle necessary to tell the story
correctly I have taken on a co-author we
found the literature necessary to do it
in proper scientific form that this came
from you but I want to mention your
co-authors name yeah
Debbie seasick okay I'm and Debbie was
an excellent co-author strong
contributor to the paper anyway we put
together over the course of a year I
took a break from effectively my real
dissertation work and wrote a paper dick
thought it was a fantastic paper he was
blown away by this wide remember the
revisions and I remember this was like I
mean if I think about what's on the line
like this combines one of these freak
situations where you're using
evolutionary theory to protect to
predict something and in this case it's
at the level of molecular biology so
with Darwin's our orchid it's a tongue
and with dicks thing its behavior in
naked mole-rats
this thing is actually at a molecular
level yeah and it couldn't be more
important
if mice are going to be the major system
in which we are going to test drugs
which are highly sensitive to what
histological repair yep it's it's so
profound on several different levels
that I'm super energized about getting
this into the world I'm it's
transformative dick looks at the paper
he says this is fantastic he puts me
through the wringer to get it really
tight we get it tight we send it to
George Williams the the but number one
guy in the world and number one
senescence guy at the evolutionary level
in the world and he writes a beautiful
recommendation letter for this piece
we're going to send it to nature George
Williams tells nature you need to take
this piece very seriously we send it to
nature and they send it back with one of
their absurd form letters that says that
the nature of the article is such that
it's probably not a limited interest to
their readers and we're you know I mean
we had a good laugh about that you know
it's cancer it's an
it's it's it's it's so bad like this is
a response that indicates either
malfeasance or analyze a program to or
or the the janitor ended up responding
who didn't know anybody it's the
craziest thing and you know the cherry
on top is that they're turning down
George Williams recommendation like how
great do they know who he is like what
were in what on what plan on what planet
do you turn down his recommendation to
look at something about senescence so
anyway I get back this rejection and I
have purposefully not shown Carol
Greider the paper in preparation which I
am afraid she might have read some way
the reason I didn't show it to her was
because I wanted to preserve her
independence as a reviewer for the paper
I was hoping because I still thought she
was an ally of mine I was hoping that
nature would send it to her to review
and that she would look favorably on it
especially since it was you know very
clear that she's unsure was her lab
right it was made the confirmation yeah
and I another thing I forgot I asked her
at some point something that now rings
in my ears I asked her Carol you've now
got this result about no actually lab
lab mice have long tumors but wild mice
have short telomeres that's a big result
a hell of a delta where are you gonna
publish it so that I can cite it my
paper which is the natural thing to do
and she says we're not going to publish
it we're going to keep the information
in-house that was her phrase I was too
young to understand what the hell she
was talking I'll be honest I'm 54 I
don't quite understand it myself well
it's so heartbreaking what she has
effectively done is decided I could
publish this result then everyone would
have huge but then I'm on a level
playing field with everybody else if I
don't publish this result I have a
stream of papers I can get it then I can
start predicting other results nobody
will know
how I am doing that thing I will look
like a super genius and so holding it in
house is a mechanism for a whole slew
lepape to be to be 100 you can afford to
bend over backwards and not make
inferences let's say the following
holding it in house is in a seemingly
inexplicable decision in science but for
for the fact that it fits at least one
story of this kind which is that it is
consistent with wishing to publish a
stream rather than the source of the
information that would allow you so you
can either do one discovery or you can
do a stream of predictions and that
makes a certain amount of sense given
the ruthlessly competitive grant winning
environment and we don't know exactly
what happened but there is no world that
I know of in which you you're allowed to
hold back that kind of information
because in part of what's on the line
right so I mean this is not just a
question of academic interest you know
because these mice are used for medical
testing but not even that it's medical
testing but it's also all of the science
relative at least to cancer senescence
wound healing all of the science that is
stacked right on these mice right is
contingent on their function relative to
their TS is all competent right
you're letting year after year of this
stuff accumulate it's malpractice at an
incredible level so I don't know that
she has turned on me but I call her up
and I say Carol we are stunned to find
that our paper was turned away without
review from nature without review
without review we need your help
can I send you the paper and have you
look at it and she says yes and I send
her the paper and she sends back the
paper with
an unbelievable number of intense
criticisms that are not sensible
she pans the paper does not believe it
will still have I have that paper I have
that paper with her handwriting I
believe I also have the FedEx envelope
in which she send it to me but she hates
the paper and I have now forgotten a bit
of the sequence but as I am attempting
to fix this up for another journal
oh here's sorry I hate to tackle this
story but it simply won't get it I told
this is enough
I haven't told it in a very long time
after the rejection from nature after
carol has seen the paper and said it's
cruddy I get a letter
I don't expect from a journal I don't I
know it exists but I'm not super
familiar with it experimental
gerontology user bare mental gerontology
says we are the editors of experimental
gerontology we have heard a rumor of
your work we're very interested would
you be willing to submit a version to
our journal and oh this is this is
happening prior to Kara looking at my
paper in panic I the only way they would
have known about this would have been
from nature or from dick or we don't
know I'm pretty sure I know based on
what they again I was too young to sort
out really what they were saying but
they indicate that they're fans of
antagonistic pleiotropy horizon so what
happened was George Williams having
heard does that regedit got rejected
contacted some friends of his and was
like you should really take a look at
this so I I begin the process of
revising it I've shown it to Carol she's
panned it I send the revised version two
experimental gerontology they send it
out for review as you know review is
blind you don't know who you're
viewers are but you can often tell who
they are it's not a subscrive the
acknowledging acknowledgments of my
paper which are now on alert about Carol
I have to thank her in the paper for the
work she did but I'm now on alert that
she's gone strange on the subject matter
of this paper and so I've broken her out
separately in the acknowledgments I
don't want to be as gracious to her
because she's being hostile to me right
I don't want to not acknowledge her so I
acknowledge her separately experimental
gerontology then I am 99% sure sends the
paper to her as the reviewer she pans it
absolutely brutal critiques just pages
and pages and pages of them they are not
high-quality critiques I could go
through every single one don't bother
this is a podcast just know I can't do
it here but I could have that no but I
didn't know what to do because she was
in line for a Nobel Prize that was well
understood I didn't want to accuse a
leading light of the field of them okay
this is exactly where I got angry at the
beginning of the podcast you [ __ ] no no
offense you were in line for a Nobel
Prize you didn't I mean I'm sorry there
is an aspect of this about giving away
your power even though you've even
acumen just you don't even have a PhD
I'm just saying at the time if you
mentioned her name yeah I would say yeah
her Nobel Prizes one of these years
right
so my point was I was in the awkward
position I didn't understand what I was
supposed to do I didn't want to send
back a review that said I don't know who
the person is who reviewed this but they
don't understand the material and all of
their critiques suck because I didn't
want to accuse somebody who was that
powerful of not getting it here's the
problem what do you do you don't
actually have evidence in the hard right
form where like you have got videotape
but on the other hand these are small
worlds this all of this is preposterous
right so I sit on the review for too
long not knowing what you don't know how
to I don't know how to handle I'm sorry
but like I have no advisor your advisor
was not equipped for the modern era he
wasn't equipped for the modern era he
was
Equipe for molecular biology that's true
I finally settle on a strategy that I
can live with and I send back a note I
send back the review and my note says I
don't know why but the this entire list
of critiques is not high quality if you
would like to point me to any of the
critiques in this list that you would
like me to address I am more than happy
to do it but I don't think it makes
sense to address the entire list and as
I recall it I hit Send on the email and
within minutes maybe it was an hour I
got back a response your paper has been
accepted for publication which blew me
away because no sense
according to regular protocol right it
makes no sense because clearly they're
supposed to send it out for review the
review were supposed to say whether it's
supposed to get published if you were
said it shouldn't be published I said I
refuse to address these critiques unless
you ask me to the editors have
overridden the reviewer they understood
the reviews were cruddy they needed me
to say that in order to justify the move
that they wanted to make they knew the
paper was good and the review was crap
so they effectively overrode normal peer
review was my paper peer reviewed well
it was by the editors who were experts
but let me jump in peer review is a
cancer from outer space it came from the
biomedical community it invaded science
the old system because I have to say
this because many people who are now
professional scientists have an idea
that peer review has always been in our
literature and it absolutely
[ __ ] has not right okay it used
to be that the editor of a journal took
responsibility for the quality of the
journal which is why we had things like
nature crop up in the first place
because they had courageous
knowledgeable forward-thinking editors
and so I just want to be very clear
because there is a mind virus out there
that says peer review is the cinah qua
non of scientific excellence yada yada
yada [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and if
you don't believe me go back and
learn that this is a recent invasive
problem in the sciences recent invasive
problem that has no justification for
existing in light of the fact not only
does it have no justification for
existing when Watson and Crick did the
double helix and this is the cleanest
example we have the paper was agreed
should not be sent out for review
because anyone who was competent would
understand immediately what its
implications were there are reasons that
great work cannot be peer-reviewed
furthermore you have entire fields that
are existing now with electronic
archives that are not peer reviewed peer
review is not peer review it sounds like
peer review it is peer injunction it is
the ability for your peers to keep the
world from learning about your work keep
the world from learning about your work
because peer review is what happens real
peer review is what happens after you've
passed the [ __ ] thing called peer
review yes okay
so the paper was accepted by
experimental gerontology they went on to
publish it this is called life slow fuse
no life slow fuse was the title as sent
to nature and I changed the title
because I did not want to compromise the
story I didn't want to confuse the seal
original submission was called life slow
fuse right we probably have a copy of
that amoris all right then
the jaren experimental gerontology paper
what is it called the reserve capacity
hypothesis okay which is a much less
catchy title but nonetheless the paper
I'm very proud of how it's written
people read it who were not expert could
understand it the abstract is extremely
clear and it ends with the clear point
that because we have unearthed we have
predicted and Carol Greider has shown
that wild mice telomeres are short and
that telomeres have been elongated by
captivity that there is a clear danger
that the mice we are using for drug
safety testing are biased in an
egregious way and the
bias would look like this a mouse that
has very long telomeres has an
indefinitely large capacity to replace
damaged tissue and it has a
vulnerability to cancer that is
preternatural 'high so we may be
overrating if we use these - we may be
overrating the danger of causing cancer
and vastly underrated the danger of tuck
cytotoxicity and in fact one of the
things so the point was you give a mouse
who's got a effectively infinite
capacity to replace its tissues a toxin
and either the toxin is so deadly that
it dies right away but if it doesn't die
right away it just eats up the insult
so those animals would lead us to
release drugs by insult what you mean is
so they're in across the damage yeah
yeah what this would cause us to do is
release drugs onto the market for human
use that are highly toxic across the
body and if if the mice if the mouse
standard was the last standard well no
even if it's not the last standard
because to say this the problem is I
mean you you can imagine how hard it is
to test on large slowly reproducing
animals what so FX of testing on humans
is very absolutely restricted so my
handle is the last cheap place it's the
last place large end data not only large
n but it's the one place that you can
make the following move you can imagine
that in many circumstances the
accelerated
lifespan the accelerated life cycle of
mice allows you to see long-term damage
as it would accrue in humans on a very
short timescale that doesn't work with
monkeys it doesn't work with human
patients it works with mice maybe but in
the case of mice with ultra long
telomeres those insults will be
invisible well let's just I want to back
up because I think this is a really
important part of the story what you're
saying is if you take an organism that
has an expected let's say 40 year
lifetime it's very expensive
of timewise to say we ran this
experiment and found that there was no
immediate damage that was visible but
towards the very end of their lives we
saw a market increase in morbidity earth
yeah I mean if you took a drug and it
knocked fifteen years off your life on
average that might not show up in any
notable way in a short term study
pressure - right and nobody is gonna
want to let drugs you know you don't
want to wait 4050 years to find out what
happens to these patients so what we do
is we make the assumption that if we
give large amounts of a drug to an
animal that lives a very short life we
will see those effects early and if the
animal happens to have ultra long
telomeres you won't see those effects
early so it's a perfect storm for
causing us to release drugs that should
never have been released into public can
you think oh I sure can Vioxx for
example so Vioxx was discovered to do
heart damage right heart damage how do
you why do we know that it's hard to
know - well the thing about hearts a
hearts for reasons we can get into maybe
another time hearts have a very low
capacity for self repair right that's
why they're fun or much turnover not
much capacity for repair not much
turnover now there's an adaptive reason
for that but but hearts don't repair
themselves very well in a healthy person
and when they fail it's hard to ignore
right if somebody who's 30 has their
heart fail there's questions asked right
so anyway Vioxx was released into the
public having passed drug safety yes
this isn't the only system that doesn't
have a lot of mitosis
like for example neurons neurons don't
have a lot cartilage doesn't have a lot
your eye cells don't now note all of the
tissues I've just mentioned the last
time you heard about anybody having you
know cancer of the cartilage of their
knee cancer of the heart no think of
brain cancer tends to be glial glial
cells exactly so the tissues at a very
low capacity for self repair right do
tend to wear out and they don't tend to
get cancer which is exactly what
predictions of my paper right okay so
Vioxx is known to do heart damage that
created a big scandal because how the
hell did it get through drug safety
testing turns out a lot of drugs have
done this we've seen it Gleevec fen phen
erythromycin your doctor probably still
doesn't know their way through my son
does heart damage right there's all of
these cases of drugs that were released
and then later understood to do heart
damage now my claim is they don't
actually do heart damage they do
cellular damage and they are gonna be
only saying you yeah yeah yeah Jesus is
like another layer of this thing it's
like a huge [ __ ] nightmare right
because but it's this thing about like
perseverance and disagree ability you've
got all sorts of things that sound like
something that invalidates the theory
and then it sort of theories upon
theories that allow you to see the
original simplicity of the idea I see
the original idea is very simple yeah
but if you know a lot of like weird
facts about what you think are just mice
or something about hearts
you can't put together what is going on
the idea that the ambient damage is only
manifest in the heart because that's the
one system you know or the neuro system
that like really doesn't have a lot of
mitosis so well piece of advice to
anybody who finds themself in remotely
similar waters mmm-hmm the signal that
you are on the right track is that stuff
starts canceling complexity in the story
which has accumulated because something
was missing it's disappearing and okay
you you begin to take on a model anyway
so yes we've got a situation where we've
got a bunch of drugs mysteriously
producing damage so they've got a paper
that's out you've got a real-world
application you've got an a theory
coming out of evolutionary theory it's
making a molecular prediction yep
successfully predicts Mouse telomeres
one of the world's leading labs has
confirmed the prediction yeah where are
we now what will you wait year is half
God well let's see the paper came out in
my recollection and to just to be
horrible about this is that your [ __ ]
Department at the University of Michigan
which has some great people is also
holding you back and enervating you year
after year by not allowing because this
is this is groundbreaking stuff this is
nobel quality work at least one or two
times over in my opinion I could be
wrong and biased because of your brother
I'm your brother but what concerns me
here is is that you are not comfortable
with what this story really might be no
I'm look it's not my not mine to judge
I'm very proud of this work and yeah but
the problem bread is is the Jerry Coyne
and Richard Dawkins did not know the
dick Alexander Leonard hayflick and
George Williams yeah we're all on this
thing because that community had broken
down you know the irony is I sent a
letter to Dawkins when this was going on
asking for his help and he sent back a
letter saying this is very interesting
it's not my area of specialty you should
talk to Bill Hamilton and I was in the
process of writing a letter to Bill
Hamilton on on Dawkins suggestion at the
point that Bill Hamilton came back from
Africa having he was pursuing a remote
hypothesis about humans having
accidentally unleashed aids into the
world with polio vaccine but anyway Bill
Hamilton I'm sorry just not everybody's
gonna know this is a guy who came up
with inclusive fitness yes he was one of
the great geniuses of evolutionary
biology in the late 20th century he was
held back by John Maynard right I don't
know that story I you know the Maynard
is interviewed on web of stories we made
under Smith yes sorry yeah Maynard Smith
that right yeah and Maynard Smith talks
about like you know it was very
unfortunate I didn't really understand
who he was you should check it out it's
pretty amazing well as long as we're
doing this yeah years after this story
had cooled yeah I ran across a paper
from John Maynard Smith that I now don't
remember exactly what its nature was but
it appeared to predict
my whole story uh-huh right and John
Maynard Smith was dead I couldn't
contact him I really wanted to say oh my
god you nailed it right but anyway um so
I was in the process of writing to Bill
Hamilton to get his help you know he was
sort of on a par with George Williams
and he went into a coma on his trip back
from Africa having contracted malaria
and then there was I think complication
with the aspirin that he took or
something and he never woke from his
coma and he died tragically so he never
got the letter and who knows what he
would have done okay that's that's it's
a tragic and interesting story but
hayflick was positive towards you
Williams was positive towards you and
dick Alexander those were the three that
blew me away that's a huge amount of
force a lot of firepower and it wasn't
enough but here's the punchline to the
story effectively at the point that my
paper is out right and it very directly
alleges the danger with yeah these drugs
being released when they're not safe and
the drugs have started emerging and
turning out now you say and the
government is now really interested okay
and what's going on the government puts
together a FDA Commission to study the
question of the book that they put out
literally a book that they put out at
the end of their study is called the
future of drug safety it opens a
blue-ribbon panel it it's not exactly
clear what it was what is clear is that
you can search the manuscript of this
book nowhere does it mention Mouse
antagonist it doesn't mention
antagonistic pleiotropy it doesn't
mention the genus mus it doesn't mention
telomeres it's not in there it's alleged
in the literature in broad daylight that
this is what is causing this yeah and
well that now you're see this is the
vampire effect where you don't exist if
nobody reacts right and so I start going
to members of the press I think this is
a huge goddamn story somebody is gonna
make if promote career on it and I call
it members of the press and it's always
the same right always the same always
the same they're very excited about
story initially right a reporter the
reporter is exciting yep and then the
reporter talks to someone talking to
someone and then either they stop
returning your call yes or they say I'm
sorry the story doesn't hang together
its again and again and again yeah and
there's just nothing you can do what I
said about the the distributed idea
suppression complex yeah
and the people who MANET don't even know
what they arm up for most of them they
don't know what role they're playing
with you look you see the same thing
with like string theory because none of
the reporters are actually string
theorists so they're dependent upon this
you saw this with this woman alleging
that she had the Epstein story three
years earlier but that the editors said
well we might lose access to the baby
pictures of the Royal grandchildren like
the you know you're seeing this with
catching kill there's this I mean I want
you to take this seriously you're just
showing a part of what I'm calling the
disc the distributed idea suppression
complex we have 50 years of such stories
yeah and it happens that in our family
three out of four of us created such a
story trying to get a PhD and the idea
for me is that every time you have to go
into some closed system like there's a
committee meeting or there's a Blue
Ribbon Commission or there's a peer
review process or there's a what do they
call them the panel's study groups for
grants that's where the disc lives we
know that it's localized to the things
that protect the integrity of science
it's an autoimmune disease where what we
have is an ability to stop highly
disruptive ideas from getting a hearing
in the general population of experts by
virtue of the fact that a carefully
chosen group of experts can stop
publication because look if you if
you're wrong about this stuff there's a
cost yeah it's not it's not cheap now I
mean in fact
it would have been career-ending I I'm
pretty sure had I've been I don't know
that it would be career-ending if it was
done in good faith but you know this is
my problem with this is that you're
sitting on one of the great scientific
stories I would say that I've ever heard
but you know I'm sort of kind of saying
well Brent what happens next you know
obviously I know a lot of this stuff I
forgotten it but I live this with you
yeah and this is I can vouch that this
is more or less the order of events as
it was taking place as we didn't
understand what was happening yeah so I
have to go through the final Carol
Greider chapter in order for this story
to fully make sense with the Nobel
Prizes given that's the that's the very
tail end make sure you include okay so
at the point that my relationship with
Carol is changing its tenor and she is
becoming hostile and I'm not clear on
what's going on I contact her and I
discover through talking to her
that she and Mike are about to publish
their paper on the long telomeres of
laboratory mice so this is the Delta
between wild-type and laboratory mice
yeah
and I'm shocked because she's told me
they're keeping an in-house and instead
they've got a paper that there she says
in final revisions there that day
submitting their final revisions to
nucleic acid research with their paper
and I say Carol can I see the paper and
she says yes and she sends me a
manuscript not the preprint of the paper
he sends me a manuscript of the paper
no acknowledgments no figures and I
contact her and I said can I see the
acknowledgments and the figures she
sends them to me and I contact her and I
say Carol I'm disturbed
this was my hypothesis that you were
testing I should probably be an author
on this paper but at the very least I
need to be an acknowledgement in this
paper so that I can go back and point to
it and say be changes everything that it
was a prediction it was
just something was stumbled upon
absolutely yeah and her response is I
have been through my email and I see no
evidence of the communications you are
talking about now when I said at the
beginning that hold her I had called her
that was my that was my air this is such
[ __ ] I mean I don't swear a lot on
this program yeah but this is such
[ __ ] academic petty stupid ass
[ __ ] this is like none of the great
stories of all time it's one of the
great stories of all time maybe and
human life hangs in the balance
today right okay so Carol does get
awarded the Nobel Prize Carol Greider
Elizabeth Blackburn and Shostak Shostak
who mentions at the point that the Nobel
Prize is awarded and he was shocked as
all hell to get a Nobel Prize because
his work was so deep in the history of
telomeres that we just didn't expect it
and suddenly no I should say I want to
be very clear yeah all of these people
have made fantastic noble worthy tell
discoveries there's zero allegation that
these people weren't deserving no
absolutely no and they you know Carol
and Elizabeth got their Nobel Prize for
the discovery of telomerase which is a
huge huge progress so anyway I don't
deny that they were worthy of this prize
but what Carol Greider does with her
Nobel lecture right Nobel lecture being
the biggest lecture a scientist will
ever give the lecture and filmed and
filmed is she delivers a paper in which
she very oddly has now embraced my
entire set of hypotheses about the
effect she has come over from the
comparison between the paper of mine
that she panned and said didn't make any
sense she is now a total convert to the
idea that senescence across the body is
being caused by hayflick limits that are
telomere basica and this is the first
public incident that we know of in which
the delta between the negative comments
about on your paper which is not an
anonymous peer review we have that bit
have it in an envelope from her got it
and it's immediately after the Nobel
Prize that the wisdom of that line of
thinking is embraced right but there's
more to the Nobel lecture so she spends
her Nobel lecture on what is admittedly
a very beautiful presentation of the
connection between telomeres and
senescence she goes through tissue after
tissues as cirrhosis of the liver is
what happens when you have short
telomeres liver etc she goes through
tissue after tissue
she projects the data the blot actually
from the paper with Mike Heymann the
paper that I should have been a
co-author on yeah she projects it on the
screen but she does some weird freaking
dance where she instead of describing
the long telomeres of laboratory mice as
a major bug in the system she describes
it as a happy accident effectively
because it allows us to test certain
things like oh isn't it delightful that
they have long tumors it's like what the
hell are you doing there is so much
riding on correcting this and you're
presenting it like it just a bonus and
she in her presentation she's got
several experiments that I did not know
she had run that I had suggested to her
I said you know things like Carol do you
have any idea if a cell has many
different telomere lengths is it the
shortest telomere that controls how many
reproduction of the cell can do is she's
run that experiment interesting lo and
behold it's the shortest telomere it's a
good guess but anyway so she goes
through this there's no mention of me
there's no mention of the actual
implications of the the long telomeres
for things like science and safety
testing and all of that and I can't seem
to raise the issue of the safety
question with anybody right at best
I get journalists who are interested
until they call somebody and the
somebody's on the other end I know what
they say they say everybody knows that
mice aren't great models in fact there's
a paper out that says something like the
mice lie it's not about this issue it's
just about the fact that mice aren't a
perfect match the issue in question
could be solved it could be addressed
thoroughly and for all I know
once the Jack's lab figured out what
they were doing for all I know they
quietly have fixed this and there was a
pride you know I've heard that there was
a private meeting in which they decided
oh look this is the thing yeah you see
something like this in statistics
everybody knows that most distributions
that are bell-shaped are not normal
right and on the other hand we all use
normal distributions and as a result
there are lots of things that at one
level
everybody knows yeah but don't percolate
down to the important layers in which we
test things and I don't know where like
you and I have never been able to fully
put together because we're not molecular
researchers and I'm not even a biologist
how important are these results how
robust are they has there been a change
this is a quiet world at some level it's
a quiet world but I think what I have
concluded yeah
working backwards from the phenomenology
of the field and how it reacts to this
problem is that there's a tremendous
amount resting on failing to acknowledge
the error even though the error was
obviously an honest error to begin right
they would rather sweep it under the rug
I mean imagine you've got all these
knockout mice right these knockout mice
there's a major investment in them it
takes a lot of work to knock a
particular central you got a single
point of failure right whose projections
are tendrils into everything right and
you've got how many careers built on
papers that are now such this is like a
neighbor this is like a centralized your
reproducibility crisis yes it's it's
that bad or worse okay and and you know
what happens if let's say somebody hears
this podcast and they
check into it and they find out lo and
behold this story is true yeah well now
the FDA has a problem
what were we whizzing I don't want to
get too far out over our skis we have
enough listeners that people will get a
chance to hear an unbelievable story and
if there are things in the story that
are not true or misremembered or unkind
or there been changes or maybe we don't
really fully understand how the drug
testing works I'm open and I want to be
very clear and I want this in the
podcast I'm open to the idea that the
most straightforward implications of the
story are subject to adjustment however
having lived the story I can say that
this was an egregious story at multiple
points with conflicts between the
evolutionary community the biomedical
community the professional publishing
community this is a terrible story and
it's also an amazing and beautiful and
wonderful story you know I felt really
lousy at the beginning of this podcast
goading you and prodding you but I'm so
bored of you no offence as the guy who
stood up to the funny kids at Evergreen
and you know we know what's in the heads
of these people if you're at Evergreen
you're not that good Yeah right and that
was like this is the I just want to be
open about it all right look I I
appreciate it and I and I'm glad to have
this story out the story has many
different layers of meaning I know I
remember where I was when I finally sat
down to watch Carroll Grider's Nobel
lecture and I had one of the oddest
experiences of my life
I was I was actually in a hammock
watching her lecture watching her
present my hypothesis without my name
anywhere on it and then she projects
this image from her paper with Mike
Eamon and I was flooded
with two simultaneous emotions that are
just completely incompatible right I've
never felt anything like it I was
absolutely elated to see my work
projected on a no-bail stage right that
changed me you know I called the horse
and rider problem no the point of the
official complex of science is to knock
the rider and take the horse where the
horse is the theory and the rider is the
attribution well this was it I was
elated and livid simultaneously and I
still almost feel what it was almost
like my body was trying to figure out
1/2 supposed to feel one thing and the
other feels the other but this story has
many levels of importance personally it
gave me the ability i was already as you
are very good at not being persuaded by
the fact that everybody else disagrees
with you that that has an implication
every great idea starts with a minority
of one and you have to be able to endure
bright alone with a great idea in order
to advance the ball significantly this
story was so extreme and so clear in the
end that it just left
no doubt and I must say I don't know how
young students can arrange to confront
material so that if they're really good
they get a clear demonstration like this
that they're really good so they know
how to keep going I think you're selfish
and I don't mean to be horrible about it
I think that this story is an
inspiration I've lived the story with
you I have my own version of the story
where instead of it being the slide from
the paper of Grider and human it's
equations that are known as the cyber
Witten equations and you see what you
did with somebody else putting you know
putting it up on a board it starts to
change the field you suddenly say you
mean I'm not an idiot right and what I'm
claiming is that
the next layer of this is well why don't
you just submit a paper if you have
ideas submit a paper submit a paper
submitted paper who is this [ __ ]
supposed to fool well right and this
this I mean I just I think the idea is
that if you have a seat on the exchange
yeah you know that by submitting a paper
your paper will get reviewed because you
have you present a credible threat it
doesn't occur to you that what you're
saying is effectively like let them eat
cake now somebody whose paper is going
to be reviewed by the person who's like
holding them back now this is exactly
when Jerry Coyne came at me yeah with
you know Brett doesn't understand his
Explorer mode stuff is is nonsense and
then Richard Dawkins echoed it Brett
doesn't understand natural selection um
and you know if he did he'd submit a
paper my feeling is I lived this story
and you're gonna pretend that there is
even a mechanism look here's my per to
get a proper hearing bosal alright yeah
I think that you Pia and myself are
indicative of an entire layer of gen-x
pakad emissions and now probably
millennial academics whose work was
suppressed and we don't feel comfortable
saying these words which is that the
purpose of the university system in the
time that we were there was in large
measure to make sure that big disruptive
new ideas did not upset the applecart
because there was the ability to deny I
mean this is what you guys call
interference competition which is that
you keep people from sitting down in the
chairs in a game of musical chairs and
then the idea is we have lovely parting
gifts for our contestants Doug pressure
who did green fluorescent protein ends
up driving a shuttle bus in Huntsville
Alabama features in this you know was
the front page of the science times a
year later he's still driving a [ __ ]
shuttle bus in Huntsville Alabama
meanwhile we're being told that
Americans don't care about stem we're
not really good at science but
thank God thank God our friends in Asia
are amazing at science because as bad as
our children are at thinking for
themselves we've got huge numbers of
people who want to come from China South
Korea India and Taiwan in order to do
the study in the labs which is actually
work and I'm the guy who found the
secret study in 1986 which says hey
we're gonna have to pay these American
academic over six figures very soon
because of the supply-demand
relationships and then they took away
the demand curves and they only showed
the supply curves they said it was a
demographic rather than an economic
analysis of price and wage certainly
didn't enter into it like our problem is
that the American scientific enterprise
headquartered in the National Science
Foundation National Academy of Sciences
and our university systems is fraudulent
and it serves to suppress radical new
ideas and I'm not saying everything is
guaranteed to be right about your story
but this is a story that you and Carol
should have Ward out in public without
you're submitting into a system where
you don't know who reviewed this you
don't know how to respond to the
comments you can't measure the Delta
where somebody in one year says this is
crap and the next year they say this is
my theory right and what I want I would
love to invite Carol Greider onto this
program because I think she deserves the
right to rebut what you're saying yep
that'd be cool and an Elizabeth
Blackburn is fantastic I'd love that and
these are great sites this frankly
you're gonna say this is me being too
nice yeah I'd even like Carol to come
clean and just put this behind us I'm
not you know at this point it's not a
question of that Brett there is you have
the right to offer somebody a hand up
yeah but you're skipping the step of let
me be blunt
how many universities offered you a
position after you were run out of this
crappy Evergreen State College
by a weak president who refused to stand
up for academic freedom freedom of
speech and anti racism which you
exemplify professorship zero
how many biology looks lectures were you
invited to give a top-tier AAU
universities American Association of
universities not associate American okay
what the [ __ ] is that I mean let's just
say the word [ __ ] a lot because I had
Andrew yang in that chair I don't say
[ __ ] a lot yeah okay so the idea is you
could have a Maoist insurgency against a
student of Dick Alexander who's
supported by George Williams with
support from Leonard hayflick he's
predicting something from evolutionary
theory registers in molecular biology it
may have drug-testing implications and
like nothing silence and you're
terrified to talk about this I don't
think I'm terrified to talk well I'm
sorry
can you tell me something where have you
told you you have a podcast yeah where
is the story written up where is the
story lodged you and I have the ability
to lodge it I'm forcing you to do this
on my podcast I haven't heard you do a
podcast about this I hear you talking
about free speech I hear you doing
things with the heterodox Academy I hear
you doing things in the intellectual
dark web something with and II know
something with antifa okay the whole
purpose of the intellectual dark web is
to keep the channel open based on merit
because if we do something like the
diversity of ideas you know for all I
know the people who are suppressing you
are more diverse than you are you know
okay these are ideas that needed to come
out there are health implications
potentially of these ideas this is not
ethical to suppress in fact it's not
ethical for you not to talk about not to
be rude no no look I get this I tried
for a decade to get this story to come
out now I'm sure I would have been less
aggressive on the social front I would
have let Carol go in order to get the
story out and get the drug safety issue
addressed I don't know I don't know what
you regard that as
maybe that's on its that question of
this look there is a Carol Greider an
Elizabeth Blackburn and everybody else
in like senescence land
Judith Campisi who knows everybody's got
a problem
which is there's way too much
transparency and there's too little
funding and there's not enough autonomy
and there's too much peer review and for
whatever reason a new game is cropped up
where everybody says we need more
transparency more diversity we need to
make sure that we're not wasting
taxpayer dollars we have you know
evermore oversight all of this is
denaturing our society we have to
compete with China now we're gonna have
issues with Iran and Russia and we are
losing our minds because we are serving
a baby-boom group almost like you pick a
leading University it is headed
currently by a baby boomer
it's almost true without even telling if
I if I ask you hey Brett pick a
university don't tell me which one it is
I will tell you that the number of
administrators that that university has
soared above the levels of admissions
the tuition has soared above medical
inflation which is above regular
inflation if I ask you about the grant
structure older professors have winning
more grants and younger people are
winning fewer grants this is a giant
complex I am going to have somebody from
sugar baby University which is a subset
of seeking arrangement because the baby
boomers made student debt non
dischargeable in bankruptcy and now this
group is offering older men the ability
to date younger women with an allowance
right so where we're starting to get
into gray area sex work where the baby
boomers to keep this lifestyle to which
they've become accustom are effectively
enslaving well they're hoarding
well-being on every front including the
second well which is no surprise at all
here's my claim we are in a holding
pattern I'm in my 50s you're in your 50s
I've done work that has never seen the
light of day you've done work that's
never seen the light of day pee is done
work that's never seen the light of day
I don't know about Heather my claim is
it's time
to crash-land the plains into the
control tower it's enough wholeheartedly
agree okay
Bret it's been an absolute pleasure
having you on the portal come back
anytime I want to say that anybody who
is miss portrayed by this podcast is
welcome we are not claiming to have
absolute in universal knowledge you are
more than welcome to correct the story
if you have knowledge about this that
checks out and but the problem is is
that this is a story that needs to be
told it's like the story of Margo
O'Toole and David Baltimore that played
out at MIT when I believe that she found
that she couldn't reproduce the work of
dr. M menisci Carrie and of course the
system turned on the person who is
trying to say hey I'm seeing
irregularities I'm seeing problems we
have a biomedical complex that needs
whistleblowers it needs iconic class it
needs challengers the food pyramid has
been off for years our health
recommendations are completely off I
think that this is an essential story
you need to move out of intellectual
dark web stuff which was about keeping
the pipe open let's somebody else do
that and it is time to hire you as a
professor at a top-tier University and
I'll be happy to talk to you about what
happened when you and Richard Dawkins
encountered each other on stage in
Chicago because I think in terms of pure
evolutionary theory it is time to boost
a young Richard Dawkins who contributed
two of the most important ideas in the
form of extended phenotype in the meme
which largely dislodges the old Richard
Dawkins and his hatred of religion which
has appeared to take over his thinking
as regards his own contributions to
biology we got a lot of work to do now
question all right my friend
well thanks for having me thanks for
coming you've been through the portal
with dr. brett weinstein professor in
exile from the Evergreen State College
please subscribe on Apple or on stitcher
or on Spotify wherever you listen to
podcasts navigate over to a YouTube
channel
and not only subscribe but remember to
click the bell icon to be No
fight with our next episode drops and
hope to see back on the next episode of
the portal be well over
[Music]